well how hard is it to get the humanoid
robot Atlas
to do some of the things it's recently
been doing let's forget the flips and
all of that let's just look at the
running
maybe you can correct me but there's
something about running I mean that's
not careful at all that's your falling
forward
you're jumping forward and are falling
so how hard is it to get that right our
first humanoid
we needed to deliver natural looking
walking you know we took a contract from
the army they wanted a robot that could
walk naturally they wanted to put a suit
on the robot and be able to test it in a
gas environment and so they wanted that
the motion to be natural
and so our goal was a natural looking
gate it was real it was surprisingly
hard to get that to work and we but we
did build an early machine
uh we called it pet man prototype it was
the Prototype before the Pac-Man robot
and it had a really nice looking
gate where you know I would stick the
leg out it would do heel strike first
before it rolled onto the toe so you
didn't land with a flat foot you
extended your leg a little bit
um but even then it was hard to get the
robot to walk where when you're walking
that I fully extended its leg and
essentially landed on an extended leg
and if you watch closely how you walk
you probably land on an extended leg but
then you immediately flex your knee as
you start to make that contact
and getting that all to work well
took such a long time in fact I I
probably didn't really see the nice
natural walking that I expected out of
our humanoids until maybe last year
and the team was developing on our newer
generation of Atlas you know some new
techniques
for developing a walking control
algorithm and they got that natural
looking motion as sort of a byproduct of
a of a just a different process they
were applying to developing the control
so that probably took 15 years 10 to 15
years to sort of get that from from you
know the Petman prototype was probably
in 2008 and what was it 2022 last year
that I think I saw a good walking on
Atlas if you could just like link on it
what are some challenges of getting good
walking so is it uh
is this is this partially like a
hardware like actuator problem is it the
control is it the artistic element of
just observing the whole system
operating in different conditions
together I mean is there some kind of
interesting
quirks or challenges you can speak to
like the heel strike yeah so one of the
things that makes the like this straight
leg uh a challenge
is you're sort of up against a
singularity a mathematical single
Singularity where you know when your leg
is fully extended it can't go further
the other direction right there's only
you can only move in One Direction and
that makes all of the calculations
around how to produce
twerks at that joint or positions makes
it more complicated and so having all
the mathematics so it can deal with
these singular configurations is one of
many challenges uh that we face and I'd
say in in the
you know in those earlier days again we
were working with these really
simplified models
so we're trying to boil all the physics
of the complex human body into a simpler
subsystem that we can more easily
describe in mathematics and sometimes
those simpler subsystems don't have all
of that complexity of the straight leg
built into them and so um what's what's
happened more recently is we're able to
apply techniques that let us take the
full physics of the robot into account
and and deal with some of those strange
situations like this like the straight
leg so is there a fundamental challenge
here that it's uh maybe you can correct
me but is it under actuated are you
falling under actuated is the right word
right you can't you can't uh push the
robot in any direction you want to right
and so that that is one of the hard
problems of of uh like at Locomotion and
you have to do that for natural movement
it's not necessarily required for
natural movement it's just required
you know we we don't have you know a
gravity force that you can hook yourself
onto to apply uh an external force in
the direction you want at all times
right the only the only external forces
are being mediated through your feet and
how they get mediated depending on how
you place your feet and uh you know you
can't just uh you know God's hand can't
reach down and give and push in any
direction you want you know so is there
uh is there some extra challenge to the
fact that Alice is such a big robot
there is the humanoid form is um
attractive in many ways but it's also a
challenge in many ways
um
you have this big upper body that has a
lot of mass and inertia
um and throwing that inertia around
increases the complexity of maintaining
balance and as soon as you pick up
something heavy in your arms you've made
that problem even harder
and so uh in the early work in the leg
lab and in the early days at the company
yeah we were pursuing these quadruped
robots which had a
kind of built-in simplification you had
this big rigid body and then really
light legs so when you swing the legs
the leg motion didn't impact the body
motion very much all the mass and
inertia was in the body but when you
have the humanoid that doesn't work you
have big heavy legs you swing the legs
it affects everything else
and so
dealing with all of that interaction
does make the humanoid a much more
complicated platform
and I also saw that at least recently
you've been doing more explicit modeling
of the stuff you pick up yeah which is
very really
interesting so you have to what model
the shape
the weight distribution
I don't know what like you have to under
like include that as part of the
modeling as part of the planning because
okay so for people who don't know
uh so Atlas at least in like a recent
video like throws a heavy bag throws a
bunches yeah stuff so what what's
involved in uh picking up a thing a
heavy thing
uh and when that thing is a bunch of
different non-standard things I think it
also picked up like a barbell
and to be able to throw in some cases
what are some interesting challenges
there
so we were definitely trying to show
that the robot and the techniques were
applying to the robe Atlas let us deal
with heavy things in the world because
if the robot's going to be useful it's
actually got to move stuff around yeah
and that and that needs to be
significant stuff that's an appreciable
portion of the the body weight of the
robot
and we also think this differentiates us
from the other humanoid robot activities
that you're seeing out there mostly
they're not picking stuff up yet
and not heavy stuff anyway
um but just like you or me you know you
need to anticipate that moment you know
you're reaching out to pick something up
and as soon as you pick it up your
center of mass is going to shift
and if you're gonna you know turn in a
circle you have to take that inertia
into account and if you're going to
throw a thing you know you've got all of
that has to be sort of included in in
the model of what you're trying to do
so the robot needs to have some idea or
expectation of what that weight is and
then and sort of predict you know think
a couple of seconds ahead how do I
manage my now my my body plus this big
heavy thing together to get and and
still maintain balance right and so um I
I uh that's a big change for us and I
think the tools we've built are really
allowing that to happen quickly now some
of those motions that you saw in that
most recent video we were able to create
in a matter of days it used to be it
took six months to do anything new you
know on the robot and and now we're
starting to develop the tools that let
us do that in a matter of days and so we
think that's really exciting it means
that the ability to create new behaviors
for the robot is going to be um
a quicker process so being able to
explicitly model
new things that it might need to pick up
new type of things and you know to some
degree you don't you don't want to have
to pay too much attention to each
specific thing right
um there's sort of a generalization here
yeah
um obviously when you grab a thing you
have to conform your your hand your end
effector to the surface of that shape
but once it's in your hands it's
probably just the mass and inertia that
matter and the the shape may not be as
important yeah and so you know for some
in some ways you want to pay attention
to that detailed shape and in others you
want to generalize it and say uh well
all I really care about is the center of
mass of this thing especially if I'm
going to throw it up on that scaffolding
and it's easier if the body is rigid
what if it's there's some doesn't it
throw like a sandbag type thing that
tool bag you know you've had loose had
loose stuff in it yeah so it it managed
that there are harder things that we
haven't done yet you know we could have
had a big jointed thing or I don't know
a bunch of loose wire or rope what about
carrying another robot how about that
yeah we haven't we haven't done that yet
I guess we did a little bit of uh we did
a a little skit around Christmas where
we had two spots holding up another spot
that was trying to put you know a bow on
a tree so I guess we're doing that in a
small way
okay that's pretty good uh let me ask
the all-important question uh do you
know how much Atlas can curl
[Laughter]
have you
I mean you know this for us humans
that's really one of the most
fundamental questions you can ask
another human being
bench it probably can't curl as much as
we can yet but a metric that I think is
interesting is um you know another way
of looking at that strength
is you know the box jump so if how high
of a box can you jump onto question and
uh Alice I don't know the exact height
it was probably a meter high or
something like that it was a pretty
pretty tall jump that Atlas was able to
manage when we last tried to do this and
and I have video of my chief technical
officer
doing the same jump and he really
struggled you know the human but the
human getting all the way on top of this
box but then you know Atlas was able to
do it
um we're now thinking about the next
generation of Atlas and we're probably
going to be in the realm of a person
can't do it you know with this with the
Next Generation and the robots the
actuators are going to get stronger
where it really is the case that at
least some of these joints some of these
motions will be stronger and to
understand how high it can jump you
probably had to do quite a bit of
testing oh yeah and there's lots of
videos of it trying and failing and
that's you know that's all you know we
don't always release those those videos
but they're a lot of fun to look at
uh so we'll talk a little bit about that
uh but if can you talk to the jumping
because you talked about the walking it
took a long time many many years to get
the walking to be natural but there's
also really natural looking
uh robust resilient jumping how hard is
it to do the jumping well again this
stuff has really evolved rapidly in the
last few years you know the first time
we did a somersault
um you know there's a lot of kind of
manual iteration what is the trajectory
you know how hard do you throw it in
fact in these early days uh I actually
would when I'd see early experiments
that the team was doing I might make
suggestions about how to change the
technique again kind of borrowing from
my own intuition about how backflips
work
um
but frankly they don't need that anymore
so in the early days you had to iterate
kind of in almost a manual way trying to
change these trajectories of the arms or
the legs to try to get you know a
successful backflip to happen
but more recently we're running
these model predictive uh control
techniques where we're able to the robot
essentially can think in advance for the
next second or two about how its motion
is going to transpire and you can you
know solve for optimal trajectories to
get from A to B so this is happening in
a much more natural way and we're really
seeing an acceleration happen in the
development of these behaviors again
partly due to these
optimization techniques uh sometimes
learning techniques
so it's there's it's hard in that
there's a lot of mathematics and behind
it but we're figuring that out so you
can do model predictive control for
uh I mean I don't even understand what
that looks like when the entire robot is
in the air flying and doing a backflip
yeah I mean but but that's the cool part
right so you know yeah you know the
physics we we can calculate physics
pretty well using you know Newton's laws
about how it's going to evolve over time
and the road you know this this the sick
trick which was a front somersault with
a half twist is a good example right
you saw the robot on various versions of
that trick I've seen it land in
different configurations and it still
manages to stabilize itself and so you
know what this model predictive control
means is again the in real time the
robot is projecting ahead you know a
second into the future and sort of
exploring options and if I if I move my
arm a little bit more this way how is
that going to affect the outcome and so
it can do these calculations many of
them you know uh and and basically solve
for you know given where I am now maybe
I took off a little bit screwy from how
I had planned I can adjust so you're
adjusting in there just on the fly so
the the model predictive control lets
you adjust on the Fly
and of course I think this is what you
know people adapt as well we when when
we do it even a gymnastics trick we try
to set it up so it's as close to the
same every time but we figured out how
to do some adjustment on the Fly and now
we're starting to figure out that the
robots can do this adjustment on the fly
as well using these techniques in the
air
and so I mean it just feels from a
robotics perspective just surreal well
that's sort of the you talked about
under actuated right so when you're in
the air there's something there's some
things you can't change right you can't
change the momentum while it's in the
air because you can't apply an external
force or Torque and so the momentum
isn't going to change so how do you work
within the constraint of that fixed
momentum to still get from A to B where
you want to be that's really unfortunate
you're in the air I mean you become a
drone for a brief moment of time no
you're not even a drone because you
can't can't ever you can't hover you're
gonna you're gonna impact soon be ready
yeah are you considered like a hover
type thing or no no it's too much weight
I mean it's just it's just incredible uh
and just even to have the guts to try
backflip with such a large body
that's wild but like uh we definitely
broke a few robots trying but but that's
where the build it break it fix it you
know uh strategy comes in and you gotta
be willing to break and what ends up
happening is you end up by breaking the
robot repeatedly you find the weak
points and then you end up redesigning
it so it doesn't break so easily next
time you know through the breaking
process you learn a lot like a lot of
lessons and you keep improving not just
how to make the backflip work but
everything and how to build the machine
better yeah yeah
I mean is there something about just the
guts that
come up with an idea of saying you know
what let's try to make it to a backflip
well I think the courage to do a
backflip in the first place and and to
not worry too much about the ridicule of
somebody saying why the heck are you
doing backflips with robots because a
lot of people have asked that you know
why why why are you doing this why go to
the moon in this decade and do the other
things JFK
not because it's easy because it's hard
yeah exactly
don't ask questions okay so the uh the
jumping I mean it's just there's a lot
of incredible stuff if we can just
rewind a little bit to uh the DARPA
robotics challenge in 2015 I think which
was for people who are familiar with the
DARPA challenges
it uh was first with autonomous vehicles
and there's a lot of interesting
challenges around that and the DARPA
robotics challenge is when uh humanoid
robots were tasked to do all kinds of
uh you know manipulation walking driving
your car all these kinds of challenges
with if I remember correctly sort of
some slight capability to communicate
with humans but the communication was
very poor so it basically has to be
almost entirely autonomous you can have
periods where the communication was
entirely interrupted and the robot had
to be able to proceed yeah but you could
provide some high level guidance to the
robot basically load low bandwidth
Communications to steer it I watched
that challenge with kind of tears in my
eyes eating popcorn
but I wasn't personally losing uh you
know hundreds of thousands millions of
dollars and many years of incredible
hard work by some of the most brilliant
roboticists in the world so that was why
the tragic that's why tears came so
anyway what what have you uh just
looking back to that time what have you
learned from that experience
I mean maybe if you could describe what
it was uh sort of the setup for people
who haven't seen it well so there was a
contest where a bunch of different
um robots were asked to do a series of
tasks uh some of those that you
mentioned drive a vehicle get out open a
door go identify a valve shutter valve
use a tool to maybe cut a hole in
um a surface and then crawl over some
stairs and maybe some rough Terrain
so it was
the idea was have a general purpose
robot that could do lots of different
things
um it had to be mobility and
manipulation on board perception
and there was a contest which DARPA
likes at the time was running sort of
follow-on to the
the Grand Challenge which was let's
let's try to push vehicle autonomy along
right they they encourage people to
build autonomous cars so they're trying
to basically push an industry forward
and
um
uh we were asked our role in this was to
build
um a humanoid at the time it was our
sort of first generation Atlas robot
and we built maybe 10 of them I don't
remember the exact number
and DARPA distributed those to various
teams
um that sort of won a contest showed
that they could you know program these
robots and then use them to compete
against each other and then other robots
were introduced as well some teams built
their own robots Carnegie
um melon for example built their own
robot and uh and all these robots
competed to see who could sort of get
through this this Maze of the fastest
and again I think the purpose was to
kind of push the whole industry forward
we provided the robot and some baseline
software but we didn't we didn't
actually compete as a participant where
we were trying to uh you know Drive the
robot through this maze we were just
trying to support the other teams
it was humbling because it was it was
really a hard task and honestly the
robots the tears were because mostly the
robots didn't do it you know they fell
down
you know repeatedly
um it was hard to get through this
contest uh you know some did and and you
know they were rewarded and won but it
was humbling because of just how hard
these tasks weren't all that hard a
person could have done it very easily
but it was really hard to get the robots
to do it you know the general nature of
it the the variety of it the variety and
also that I don't know if the tasks were
sort of the task in themselves help us
understand what is difficult what is not
I don't know if that was obvious before
the contest was designed so you kind of
tried to figure that out and I think
Atlas is really a general robot platform
and it's perhaps not best suited for the
specific tasks of that contest like for
just for example
probably the hardest task is not the
driving of the car but getting in and
out of the car and that was probably you
know if you were to design a robot that
can get into the car easily and get out
easily you probably would not make Atlas
with that particular car yeah the robot
was a little bit big to get in and out
of that car right it doesn't fit yeah
this is the curse of a general purpose
robot that they're not perfect at any
one thing
but they might be able to do a wide
variety of things and and that is
that is the goal at the end of the day
you know I think we all want to build
general purpose robots that can be used
for lots of different activities
but it's hard and
um and the wisdom in in building
successful robots up until this point
have been go build a robot for a
specific task and it'll do it very well
and as long as you control that
environment it'll operate perfectly but
but robots need to be able to deal with
uncertainty if they're going to be
useful to us in the future
they need to be able to deal with
unexpected uh situations and that's sort
of the goal of a general purpose or
multi-purpose robot
and that's just darn hard and so some of
you know there's these curious little
failures like I remember one of the a
robot you know the first the first time
you start to try to push on the world
with a robot you you forget that the
world pushes back and and will push you
over if you're not ready for it and the
robot you know reached to grab the door
handle I think it missed the grasp of
the door handle was expecting that its
hand was on the door handle and so when
it tried to turn the knob it just threw
itself over it didn't realize oh I had
missed the door handle I didn't have I
didn't I was expecting a force back from
the door it wasn't there and then I lost
my balance so these little simple things
that you and I would take totally for
granted and deal with the robots don't
know how to deal with yet and so you
have to start to deal with all of those
uh circumstances well I think a lot of
us experience this in uh even when sober
but drunk too uh sort of you pick up a
thing and expect it to be
what is it heavy and it turns out to be
light yeah oh yeah and then so the same
and I'm sure if your depth perception
for whatever reason is screwed up if
you're if you're drunk or some other
reason and then you think you're putting
your hand on the table and you miss it I
mean it's the same kind of situation
yeah but
there's why you need to be able to
predict forward just a little bit and so
that's where this model predictive
control stuff comes in predict forward
what you think is going to happen
and then if and if that does happen
you're in good shape if something else
happens you better start predicting
again so we like re-re uh regenerate a
plan yeah when you don't I mean that
um that also requires a very uh fast
feedback loop of updating
with your prediction how it matches to
the actual real world
yeah those things have to run pretty
quickly what's the challenge of running
things pretty quickly a thousand Hertz
of acting and sensing quickly you know
there's a few different layers of that
you you want at the lowest level you
like to run things typically at around a
thousand Hertz which means that you know
at each joint of the robot you're
measuring position or force and then
trying to control your actuator whether
it's a hydraulic or electric motor
trying to control the force coming out
of that actuator and you want to do that
really fast
something like a thousand Hertz and that
means you can't have too much
calculation going on at that joint
um but that's pretty manageable these
days and it's fairly common and then
there's another layer that you're
probably calculating you know maybe at
100 Hertz maybe 10 times slower
which is now starting to look at the
overall body motion and thinking about
the the larger physics of of the uh of
the robot
um and then there's yet another loop
that's probably happening a little bit
slower which is where you start to bring
you know your perception and your vision
and things like that and so you need to
run all of these Loops sort of
simultaneously you do have to manage
your your computer time so that you can
squeeze in all the calculations you need
in real time in a very consistent way
and the amount of calculation we can do
is increasing as computers get better
which means we can start to do more
sophisticated calculations I can have a
more complex model
doing my forward prediction
and and that might allow me to do even
better predictions as I as I get better
and better and and it used to be again
we had
you know 10 years ago
we had to have pretty simple models
that we were running you know at those
fast rates because the computers weren't
as capable about calculating forward
with a sophisticated model but as as
computation gets better we can we can do
more of that what about the actual
pipeline of software engineering how
easy it is to keep updating Atlas like
Duke continuous development on it so how
many computers
are on there is there a nice pipeline
it's an important part of building a
team around it which means you know you
need to also have software tools
simulation tools you know so
um we have always made strong use of
physics-based simulation tools to do
some of this calculation basically
tested in simulation before you put it
on the robot but you also want the same
code that you're running in simulation
to be the same code you're running on
the hardware and so even getting to the
point where it was the same code going
from one to the other we probably didn't
really get that working until you know a
few years several years ago
um but that was a you know that was a
bit of a milestone and so you want to
work certainly work these pipelines so
that you can make it as easy as possible
and have a bunch of people working in
parallel especially when you know we
only have you know four of the atlas
robots the modern uh Atlas robots at the
company
and you know we probably have you know
40 developers there all trying to gain
access to it and so you need to share
resources and use some of these some of
the software pipeline well that's a
really exciting step to be able to run
the exact same code and simulation as on
the actual robot how hard is it to do
uh realistic simulation physics-based
simulation of of Atlas such that I mean
the dream is like if it works in
simulation works perfectly in reality
how hard is it to sort of keep workout
closing that Gap the root of some of our
physics-based simulation tools really
started at MIT and um we built some some
good physics-based modeling tools there
the early days of the company we were
trying to develop those tools as a
commercial product so we continued to
develop them it wasn't a particularly
successful commercial product but we
ended up with some nice physics-based
simulation tools so that when we started
doing like it robotics again we had a
really nice tool to work with
and the things we paid attention to were
were things that weren't necessarily
handled very well in the commercial
tools you could buy off the shelf like
like interaction with the world like
foot ground contact as they're trying to
model those contact
um events well
in a way that captured the important
parts of the interaction
was a really important element uh to get
right and to also do in a way that was
computationally feasible
um it could run fast because if you if
your simulation runs too slow you know
then your developers are sitting around
waiting for stuff to run and compile so
it it's always about efficient uh fast
operation as well so that's been a big
part of it you know I think developing
those tools in parallel to the
development of the the platform and
trying to scale them has has really been
essential I'd say to us being able to
assemble a team of people that could do
this yeah how to simulate contact period
so foot ground contact but sort of for
manipulation
um because don't you want to model all
kinds of surfaces yeah so it will be
even more complex with manipulation
because there's a lot more going on you
know and you need to capture I don't
know things slipping and moving you know
in in your in your hand
um it's a level of complexity that I
think goes above
foot ground contact when you really
start doing dexterous manipulation so
there's challenges ahead still so how
far are we away from me being able to
walk with Atlas in the sand along the
beach and
us both drinking a beer
maybe you can out of a kid maybe Atlas
could spill his beer because he's got
nowhere to put it
Atlas could walk on the sand uh so can
it yeah uh yeah I mean you know have we
really had him out on the beach you know
we take them outside often you know
rocks Hills that sort of thing even
their surround our lab in Waltham we
probably haven't been on the sand but
I'm a soft surface I don't doubt that we
could deal with it yeah we we might have
to spend a little bit of time to sort of
make that work